Do you know about the Latin x thing?
I didn't know that was the thing.
You didn't know about that. What do you
mean? I was reading this article and yeah,
it's, you know, you know, and
Latina are male and female.
Gender specific.
So the word Latin also get,
gets it done as far as,
yeah, I dunno. Yeah.
So it's supposed to be like,
that's how you Latin x that you're
supposed to say Latinex because it's just
new. It's, it's not. It's a couple
of years in the making and fuck off.
We'll see in Spanish,
the masculinized version of these
words just considered gender neutral,
but that obviously doesn't work
for some of us like myself.
And so I think it's appropriate to assign
a masculinity as gender neutral when
it isn't.
So I'm Latinex well,
it's interesting because my kids are Latin
and this is another one of the things
that we touch on to next. Yeah, there it
is. And we touch it. Oh, sorry. Go. No,
go ahead please. Well, we touch on this
a little, not this pronunciation or,
you know,
but we touch on that a little bit in
the movie of there is that feeling,
you know, when, when we went into adopt
our kids, we were just open. We were like,
look, we're, we're, we're
pretty general agewise we,
we didn't go in expecting
three kids, just, you know,
we thought one and it sort of turned
into that. But, uh, but you know,
you're open to it and you just, and, and
they ask you, well, what about ethnicity?
You know, and just go, yeah, whatever,
you know, wherever the need is,
you know, whoever needs parents,
you know, let us know. And,
but then when, when it happens
in your kids, and in my case,
my kids turned out to be Latin,
then you have the, you know,
you start to kind of think about like, oh,
well, you know, uh, is that, is that okay?
Is that kind of, you know, is that
gonna look like the white savior thing?
Is that gonna look weird? Is that I am
I, am I saying things right and whatever.
And what ends up happening is this
really wonderful thing where your family
becomes this melting pot where, you know,
at first, because of the, there's the,
the Times that we live in right now,
it is,
it's a little scary jumping into that
because you're thinking about what you
know, but you're, you know,
but you ultimately are just going
to think about who the kids are,
what their need is and how
obviously wonderful they are and,
but you,
but all of those things come up and that's
the kind of thing that wouldn't even
be, you know, why would that the,
the Latinex thing have anything to do
with my house. Well now it does. Yeah.
So I've got, I've got all that,
you know, all the time and, and uh,
I actually find it really
interesting. The next thing, no, no,
not that specifically,
but just that,
that my family is now this little
melting pot. Yeah, that part's cool.
And it's cool. I reject Latinex
completely. Well, it is, it is cool.
But it's also very strange that that is a,
and it would be a real point of concern,
like you would worry about, you know,
how do I handle this,
this culture without cultural
appropriation. How do I,
how do I bring my kid,
embrace the Latino or Latinex culture?
Like what do I, how do I handle that?
Yeah. Yeah. And how do I do it without
getting call the racist? Right.
And it gets back to what I was talking
about before where you're trying to just
put your kids' needs first and
just deal with them as children,
as individuals, as human beings, you know?
And, but at the same time, you're also,
you're, you're with other parents and
there's in the adoption community,
in really an, in every direction, there's,
there's mixed race families and
the adoption community and, uh,
and you're kind of learning from
them. And it just, I dunno, it just,
it opens up a lot of conversations
with your own kids and,
and just the movies you watch,
the, the foods you eat sometimes.
And I think it's great. No, it's great.
I think it's really, you know, the, uh,
the language thing for me it stands out
more because my whole life I've said
Latino,
like my mother's Latina and it's just
funny to me to speak Spanish speaks
fluently,
which is hilarious because Tom has some
great stories about people not thinking
he speaks Spanish because when you
look at them and you're like, oh,
this fucking American guy. Yeah. It
looks like a regular American guy,
but he speaks perfect flu.
Like I've been around him before when
he asks people questions like, Whoa,
I forgot you could do that. Yeah.
Yeah. It's like someone who you know,
that could do back flips, right. And they
just do a back flip. You're like, oh,
I forgot you could do that. Yeah, it's
true. And that throw it throws people off.
Yeah, because you look so
American and that, you mean
you look like a guy. I mean,
if you have a guy loves football stuff,
fucking American,
irregular American, but he speaks
perfect. Enrolls the RS when you go.
Even when I travel abroad, like to
Spanish speaking countries, even there,
even though Spanish speaking countries
are also melting pots, you know,
they still look at you like, Oh shit,
like, you know this mother fucker,
it's really throws people want the most.
The craziest one wasn't even
with me and my sister who,
one of my sisters who also speak Spanish,
uh,
went to the Naval Academy's Linguistics
Center to in the navy and she was in the
navy for Awhile and uh,
she learned mandarin and it was really
intense, you know, was really intense.
And we went to a restaurant
together and the,
the guy who was one of those breasts,
like a Benihana tight where they
chop stuff up and the guy was a,
someone asks like,
where he's from and he said somewhere in
China and she starts speaking Mandarin
and he dropped the thing and he was like,
like he saw a ghost and,
and she's spitting back to him
and pretty fluent Mandarin.
Wow. And he stops. And he was like, I've
never seen this before. And he's like,
I've never seen a white person do this.
And we were like, yeah, it's pretty,
pretty wild, Huh. And then
he turned to us, he goes,
I don't think you understand how
hard it is to speak this language.
And I was like, I have a pretty good
idea, I can't do it. So you know,
and then just watching it,
he was just like,
he couldn't even start cooking
your sister to learn. Um,
well she was in, when you
sign, when you get in to the,
like that Naval Institute program,
they have you going,
I think it was something like eight
hours a day, five or six days a week.
So it's really,
it's super into,
it's almost like learning
mandarin and it overwhelms people.
People drop out almost like in
a physical stress way. You know,
some people just can't
handle it like bootcamp.
And I forget how long she was in and
you know, she didn't reach the level of,
I'm super, you know, fluent
like we're speaking English.
But she was able to communicate
in Mandarin. Can she read it?
She was reading and writing.
That's the thing is she was telling me
one time about how many characters and
you know,
it was just unbelievable and like there's
sounds for expressions like I'm going
to screw up cause I don't remember it.
But she was like,
you can do something like,
oh,
and that means like means
an actual phrase, you know,
like there's so many and that,
uh,
that there's characters that
mean entire expressions as well.
That I was like,
it's just our brains are so married to
our alphabet and way of speaking that
gets a real jump to, to learn
that, you know, it's just,
it really is fascinating when you travel
and you listen to people speaking their
native tongue and you realize
how strangely different
languages are across the
entire planet. Yeah. I
mean, just unbelievable.
Like I was in Thailand this summer
and you listen to people talk,
tie and everything. Ah, everything
stretches. It's got like a stretch to it,
you know? It's like a weird, Huh? There's
W it's just very odd language. I'm like,
compare that to like German or Dutch.
Yeah.
Like the Germans got those hard
sounding really hard. Yeah.
It's like this weird difference. Yeah,
and the Latin one, the Latin root word,
like languages do have a flowy singy side.
They're kind of a nice to listen to.
It's a beautiful language.
It's really nice to listen to. I mean, I
like listening. I don't speak Portuguese.
I like listening to it. Yeah. Brazilian
Portuguese is amazing. Sounds so cool.
And I listen to them. We listen
to French music sometimes at home.
Just in the kitchen. Yeah.
Yeah. Like cooking or something.
I don't know what the hell are saying.
I like it when I write.
I listen to Spanish music when I write
because I have no idea what they're
saying.
I can do that too,
where you're listening to music at a
foreign language so that it doesn't,
it doesn't, it doesn't distract. Yeah,
yeah. Yeah. It's like, it sounds good.
It gives me a little something,
something,
but I can still think about the exact
things that I'm thinking about. Well,
I recently had this interesting
experience. I sent you one of them,
but you know the trailers
for the movie get a, Oh yeah.
The movie itself and the trailers get
dubbed into all kinds of different
languages. So you have this dialogue
that, that I wrote, you know,
or me John Road or whatever, and you get
to hear it in these different languages.
And I sent you the Spain. Spanish. Yeah.
Yeah. It's different. And I don't really,
I'm not gonna pretend that
I understand that much.
What the difference between between it is,
but that's predominantly what you speak,
right? No, no, it, no, not mother.
What I speak predominantly is just like
specifically South American and more
specifically or Peruvian dot. Oh,
okay. All right, great. So, but I mean,
I did study, I studied in Madrid
for six months and once your,
your ears are trained to it,
you can listen to someone say a
sentence and know that it's, oh,
that's from Spain. Like that's you.
Then there's the Cuban version of it,
which is crazy
version of the way they,
all the island dialects sound
dramatically different. You know,
like if you listen to somebody from Cuba,
Puerto Rico,
is it a comparison like English speakers
from America versus English speakers
from Ireland? [inaudible] it is.
Yeah. Um, and I would say, you know,
I always think of a Spain as like our
Britain, you know, in a way like the,
the language properly English is from
England. That's where the language,
that is how you speak it, Spanish
and uh, gas yet Castilian you know,
that comes from Spain, they're
speaking, Oh gee, Spanish.
And then it all kind of came over here
and it's influenced in every country has
different ways of saying things
different. Obviously different slang, um,
all different curses, all different
expressions. Completely different.
Even words like as simple as like
to pick up, you know, go ahead,
pick something up.
You know,
you say that in a Mexico or Argentina,
it literally means to fuck. So really?
Yeah. So if you're like, you know,
cuticle hideous tower,
like you're trying to,
you're saying I want to
fuck this water. Yeah, but
just not what they, I'm going
to fuck this bottle. Yeah. Yeah.
My mom told me that she was in a,
in Argentina,
like when her youth and traveled there
and it was with a bellhop and she was
like, go hit made up my letter,
which is like pickup that suitcase.
But he was like, okay, cause
she was basically in slang
saying fuck my suitcase,
you know? So it's just
by like, there's like,
there's also like severity of words,
like hold aid is the word.
Like there's so many ways to say fuck,
of course in every language.
But holidayed in Spain is like, is saying
fuck. It's like going like, oh fuck.
But like when you say it in Peru, no,
my wholeness, it's a, it's a softer,
it's not taken as severely. So it's
not, it's not red the same way.
You're not saying, you're saying,
uh, like you're complaining,
but you're like, I don't,
it's like, it's taken as like,
oh, don't mess with me. Wow.
You know? So like even when I
would say when I would go Spain,
like they were like, damn, you curse a
lot. I was like, really? And then they,
you know, we, we went over that one and
then like six months later they were like,
you actually do curse a lot all
the time. And I was like, yeah,
that's probably right.